[Music]
Final Fantasy 16 and welcome to the
state of play today I'm here to talk a
little bit about the story world and
combat system of Final Fantasy 16 as
well as you will be our all new
information regarding the game's wide
variety of RPG elements and support
systems we'll be talking you through
everything while using never-before-seen
gameplay footage running on the
PlayStation 5. I hope you'll stay with
us until the end of the show and enjoy
everything we have in store for you with
that let's get started
you all know the target
shiva's dominant
and only the dominant
Focus wyvern
you are key to this mission's success
yes sergeant
I said Focus wyvern
[Music]
oh sweet home
allow me to welcome you to the world of
Final Fantasy 16.
Final Fantasy 16 is the latest
installment in the Final Fantasy series
a storied franchise with 35 years of
History yet while this is the 16th
Mainline title in the series there's
absolutely no need to have played any of
the previous games before jumping in
with a fusion of real-time action and
RPG features Final Fantasy 16 has been
developed as the first true action RPG
in the series
using the power of the PlayStation 5 to
its fullest the game delivers an
expansive thrilling gameplay experience
which we liken to a high-speed roller
coaster ride
foreign
the protagonist of our story is Clive
rossfield and his journey takes place in
the realm of Valencia
follow the Epic tale of Clive Shield of
the grand duchy of Rosaria as it unfolds
across three distinct periods in Our
Hero's life the teens 20s and 30s
while the Story begins with Clive in his
twenties a fully playable flashback will
allow you to experience the pivotal
events that shaped his past and presence
foreign
open on this newest Final Fantasy
Adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
navigation in Final Fantasy 16 is driven
via a world map with locations being
added and updated as players progress
through the main narrative
[Music]
the world map can be opened at any time
allowing players access to all manner of
locations across ballastia
[Music]
here players will meet new friends
encounter formidable foes and uncover
great and wondrous Mysteries
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
next I'd like to talk about the combat
of Final Fantasy 16.
all the battles in the game take place
in real time and are not turn based
as Clive progresses through the story he
will learn a wide array of exciting
abilities from the icons that he
encounters
now let's take a moment to admire Clive
in action
foreign
[Music]
the abilities that Clive Wheels had
unique characteristics depending on the
icon they are derived from
players can use ability points collected
by defeating entities to unlock more
abilities or upgrade existing ones
can't decide which iconic ability to
unlock or upgrade no problem
you can let the game choose for you
Final Fantasy 16 includes a range of
timely accessories to provide support to
those players who may not be so skilled
at action games bringing them a truly
enjoyable experience
players are encouraged to equip Clive
with different combinations of these
accessories until they find the one that
perfectly matches their own play style
good
a combination I can particularly
recommend to those who may struggle with
action gameplay is the ring of timely
focus and the Ring of timely strikes
this combination allows players to
unleash a wide array of different
techniques just by pressing a single
attack Button as well as shifting into a
window of slow motion whenever Clive is
about to be hit by an attack giving them
a little extra time to hit R1 and evade
alternatively players could equip an
accessory that fully automates evasion
as I said before I really encourage
everyone to discover the combination
that works best for them
foreign
[Music]
and for those who want to concentrate on
the story don't forget to choose story
Focus mode before starting a new game
in this mode time accessories are
automatically equipped from the start
allowing players to immerse themselves
in the narrative experience without
having to worry too much with the action
[Music]
Clive will meet many characters along
his journey who will join him as friends
and allies
it keeps the black from our lungs and
how do you survive without magic said
office who becomes a mentor to Clive
[Music]
Jill friend from Clive's youth it really
is such encounters and reunions will set
Clive on a path of great personal growth
it is
[Music]
some of these companions will even
accompany Clive on his adventures
fighting alongside him and finding lots
to talk about along the way
[Music]
that said players will only need to
focus on controlling climb party members
are fully AI driven providing support
for the hero and constantly adapting and
responding to his actions
foreign
[Music]
torgel is always by Clive's side and
willing to stand by him in the face of
whatever cruel fate May befall them
torbel will act as his own accord but
players can also give him direct
commands
just don't forget to give this good boy
some treats every now and then
Goods
get her upstairs
but none will
fret about Karen I've taken care of her
fee all of it she's the best dealer
decided about you have nothing to worry
about
[Music]
have a look around
after progressing somewhat through the
game Clive will gain access to Sid's
Hideaway
[Music]
thank you here in the Hideaway Clive
will find a shop where he can purchase
new weapons armor and consumables such
as potions
foreign
[Music]
a highly skilled blacksmith works the
hideaway's forge bring in materials to
craft New Gear or upgrade existing items
after upgrading your equipment or
unlocking new abilities try accessing
the areta stone
[Music]
here players can enter a virtual
training area outside the bounds of time
and space where they are free to refine
and practice combos of their very own
once you're confident in your skills try
your hand at arcade mode and see how
your scores stack up against players
from around the world
The Hideaway is home to a lot of other
features as well
[Music]
not only will players discover a variety
of side quests here but they can also
view information on quests offered all
around ballastia
foreign
[Music]
Clive still busy saving the world
when did you get back
[Music]
ah I wasn't expecting you back so soon
thank you
[Music]
visit the hunt board to gain information
on Elite marks fearsome foes lurking
about the realm in desperate need of
slaying the Moogle will be your guide
[Music]
thank you
there's also luresman Hippocrates who
will unlock vallastia's Secrets as Clive
recounts Tales of his adventures
[Music]
I have quite the find for you today
you wish to study the tones
[Music]
here for another of my lectures and
Vivian Ninetails what is it a scholar
and strategist will be more than happy
to explain to Clive the current state of
the realm and provide information on key
players there are all kinds of
interactions and features in the
Hideaway to help players get even more
enjoyment out of their time with Final
Fantasy 16 The Changing Life
[Music]
thank you
on his travels Clive will encounter a
wide array of fearsome foes
foreign
[Music]
clash with the dominance who wield the
power of the icons
foreign
beasts who hold the surrounding lands
under their sway
mysterious constructs of the Fallen a
civilization shrouded in mystery
[Music]
and we cannot forget the icons
themselves
experience unparalleled real-time action
combat as Clive takes command of the
iconic Mite coursing through his veins
and shatters his very limits
The Shining point of Final Fantasy XV
however has to be the breathtaking icon
versus icon battles
these epic confrontations all play out
in real time allowing players to control
their very own icon with their own hands
[Applause]
[Music]
these battles differ depending on the
icon encountered and every Showdown is
unique right down to gameplay players
will experience everything from a 3D
scrolling shooter to a heavyweight
wrestling match with devastating attacks
that Encompass the entire Battlefield
these massive scale boss battles are
entirely seamless and I can promise you
heart stopping controller gripping
excitement I can't wait for you to get
your hands on the game for yourself
[Music]
nice trick
but if you can do it this is
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
a little bit
so everyone what did you think thank you
for taking the time to join us today
Final Fantasy 16 will be available
worldwide June 22nd and there's still
plenty that we've left to reveal battle
content side content endgame content and
more we hope to bring you more on these
aspects of the game in the near future
also I'm truly excited to finally be
able to reveal that Final Fantasy xv's
main theme was written and performed by
one of Japan's greatest recording
artists
we've still got a lot more in store for
you in the coming weeks and I hope you
all pre-order the game and join us in
ballastia on release day this has been
nauki Yoshida producer of Final Fantasy
16. see you again
[Music]
PlayStation